ja was erwartet man von einem
Bundeskanzler der das Sparbuch empfiehlt
und auch ja von einem
Wirtschaftsminister den ich persönlich
nicht mal eine Pommesbude führen lassen
würde das mit der Insolvenz muss ich
jetzt nicht nochmal wiederholen ja es
ist einfach in unserer Regierung glaube
ich ist mangelt an ja finanzieller
Bildung bzw der finanzpolitischen
Entscheidungen die uns einfach nach
vorne bringen vor allem wenn man sich
mal überlegt wie es um uns steht also
unsere Rente liegt ja schon auf der
Intensivstation wir stehen jetzt vorne
heftigen Rezession also gut die
Aktienmärkte die machen tatsächlich noch
eine erstaunlich gute Figur aber man
muss ja auch mal klar machen was da
schon eingepreist ist also der
Aktienmarkt Preis der bei Unternehmen
wie VW schon eigentlich ein dass das
China Geschäft quasi schon weggebrochen
ist also man muss immer vorstellen was
da momentan alles gespielt wird was da
auf dem Spiel steht und ja ich würde mir
da ja mehr Politiker wünschen wie Herrn
Heilmann der
erfolgreiche Unternehmer ist oder ja das
ist schon fast untertrieben das
pilob an Herrn Heilmann fragen wir doch
mal ihn ob er denn Herr Habeck die
Pommesbude anvertrauen würde die gerade
als Beispiel genannt wurde
Oppositionspolitiker bin kann man ja
auch mal schweigen und genießen wenn wir
von außen angegriffen wird ich bin ja
auf der anderen Seite ich glaube das mit
der Pommesbude ist eine leichte
Übertreibung ich würde es etwas
sachlicher sagen aber die Regierung und
zwar auch ihre FDP muss ich sagen hat
capitale Fehler gemacht das geht damit
los dass die gasumlage 5 Monate lang von
uns bekämpft von ihnen auch Ihnen als
Abgeordneter mehrfach dafür im Bundestag
geschimpft um dann plötzlich ein Lindner
zu sagen ah die gasumlage die erhöht ja
die Gaspreise eigentlich wollen wir sie
ja Sender 180 Grad Wände die viel zu
spät kam jetzt haben wir bei der
gaspreisbremse weder für die Unternehmen
noch für die Bürger Klarheit wir kriegt
eigentlich wann etwas
lieber als die FDP und damit Kristall
Lindner ich finde das ist ein
Teamleistung da eine schlechte
Teamleistung und ich weiß jetzt nicht
aber wir können natürlich so wie beim
Fußball auch Noten geben und da haben
sie dann habe sehr schlechte Noten
gegeben aber ich würde anderen auch
schlechte Noten geben
harte Vorwürfe an sie hier als
FDP-Politiker in der Runde die FDP
machen schlecht Job wenn ich jetzt mal
so übersetzen kann
da habe ich jetzt naturgemäß eine andere
Meinung ich weiß wir werden
mal was sehr
mist ich gebe noch einen zweiten Fehler
zu aus dem Habeck Haus des förderchaos
beim Bauen und Wohnen in diesem Jahr war
eine Katastrophe also ja es sind Fehler
passiert der Punkt ist wir müssen sie
abstellen jetzt kann es bei der
Gasanlage zu lange gedauert haben immer
das ist sie kennen meine Position
Heilmann fünf Monate das war das war zu
lang ich will auch nicht ausreden der
Punkt ist wir handeln jetzt wir werden
jetzt gehalten warum die richtig ist wir
werden ihrer Fraktion
führen sie mich nicht in Versuchung mit
ihnen mit Zitat aus ihrer Fraktion zu
kommen bitte wenn wir beide echt nicht
mehr glücklich heute der Punkt ist wir
haben mittlerweile entlastungspakete
geschnürt die 300 Milliarden Euro
aussumieren plus zwei Milliarden Euro um
die härtesten zwei die hättesten Energie
und Gaspreise abzufedern das muss
gemacht werden die Opposition weiß das
immer besser die CDU liegt die Pläne
zwar nie vor die kommt immer erst
hinterher hat meistens die Idee gegeben
noch mehr Geld aus aber der ist bei der
Frage habe die Pommesbude was ja
wirklich also was ja schon stimmt
also nicht meine die würde ich selber
führen aber also Herr habit begreift
sich viel zu sehr als klimaminister und
viel zu weniger Wirtschaftsminister also
stimmt schon da kann man jetzt sagen
okay ich bin der FDP ich bin
regierungsfragen sie nehmen mich da mit
Haftung aber ich also wir arbeiten ja
schon dagegen ich weiß dass es dass wir
nicht dafür gewählt werden was wir
verhindern aber immer ehrlich ne also
was wir vorgefunden haben nach 16 Jahren
und was wir jetzt draus machen und in
einer Geschwindigkeit in einer
Geschwindigkeit ich weiß geht euch nicht
schnell genug wenn ein Geschwindigkeit
krempeln wir gerade das Land um weil wir
viele Sachen aufholen müssen die nicht
funktionieren jetzt mal
auch zu Hermann so und bleiben einmal
auch bei der Leben zu Realität die ja
jeder wahrscheinlich von uns allein
schon beim Einkaufen empfindet ja ich
finde es schon sehr teuer geworden aber
wie sehen Sie das denn eigentlich ich
bin heute der Vertreter der kleinen
Mensch
ich will einfach die Universität
wiedergeben und wir haben vor der
Sendung noch ein bisschen gesprochen ich
was mir fehlt ist diese Bekenntnis
sowohl stand und Wachstum weil ich
glaube das fällt komplett und das
bedeutet dass wir hier ganz andere
Prioritäten haben die die Bürger und
Bürger dann noch nicht mitbekommen haben
das ist hier um dass die Klima dass die
antikapitalistische zweite Reihe bei den
Grünen und auch die SPD eigentlich das
ganze System in Frage stellen und wenn
sie ehrlich sind dann sollen sich das
bitte die Menschen auch draußen sagen
und da geht's nicht nur um Teuerung von
Lebensmittel die die Menschen hinnehmen
und also in anderen Ländern die gehen
die Leute auf der Straße ich habe noch
nie gesehen dass die Menschen hier
einfach er auch ihre Unmut auch nach
außenalisierung vor allem auch ja und um
Klima was sich auch Teile was ich mehr
davon machen will als die Priorität
Nummer eins und nicht Wohlstand und
nicht Wachstum und nicht Wirtschaft also
du würdest die Prioritäten verschieben
und Wohlstand und Wachstum auf einsetzen
ja absolut natürlich
das ist ja hier diese irre Diskussion in
Deutschland es geht eigentlich nur
ständig darum er wie verteile ich um
also das jetzt vielleicht Milliardär ein
bisschen mehr Steuern zahlen kann okay
aber dass man wirklich hier ständig ja
da glaube ich sind auch viele Wähler von
der FDP enttäuscht auch wenn es
sicherlich natürlich schwierig ist aber
ich glaube es wäre schon geboten
wirklich die Leute die hart arbeiten und
man ist in Deutschland mit 60.000 Euro
oder 80.000 Euro
auf jeden Fall
wir brauchen sehr viele Sachen wir
brauchen sicherlich eine
steuerrechtliche Entlastung ich finde
wir brauchen noch mal Diskussionen wenn
ein Mensch in Deutschland 30.000 Euro im
Jahr verdient ich frage mich warum muss
der überhaupt noch Steuern zahlen also
ich glaube darüber kann man einfach mal
diskutieren weil das ist ja gerade bei
dieser Inflation wir kommen beide aus
München wenn ich in München sowas
verdiene hätte hatte Sachen der FDP hier
vorzuwerfen dass sie die Steuern nicht
gesenkt kriegen das verstehe ich in der
Koalition das kriegen keine Mehrheit ich
will aber sagen wir haben da gerade so
gesagt Sie haben nicht 300 Milliarden
verteilt sondern sie haben 300
Milliarden Schulden aufgenommen und noch
gar nichts verteilt weil die ganzen
Gesetze gibt es alle noch gar nicht wir
haben große technische Schwierigkeiten
wir haben ein digitaler ich persönlich
bin noch eine verantwortlich dafür einen
Plan vorgelegt die man die ganze Gas-
und energiepreisbremse digital machen
könnte und nicht mit diesem Irrsinn der
doppelten Verrechnung und jeder
Energieversorger 400 müssen alle
umprogrammieren ich sage Ihnen das wird
alles schief gehen so wie das da geht
und wir haben Alternativen dazu
vorgelegt wir sagen lieber wenige
kriegen 1000 Euro als alle 300 auch das
wäre mit einem digitalen System möglich
insofern haben wir sehr wohl
Alternativen vorgelegt und wir haben das
vor allen Dingen alles seit April gesagt
und jetzt noch was mit der
Vorgängerregierung den energiekrieg
haben sie nicht angefangen sondern Putin
aber wir auch nicht und dann haben
im Bundestag geht es da eigentlich um
Lösungen und Inhalte oder kann ich mir
das so vorstellen wie heute Abend hier
da sind verschiedene Parteien die
eigentlich immer mit sich selbst
beschäftigt sind wer an was schuld ist
und wer eigentlich böse ist wie auf dem
Pausenhof ist es geht es geht
wirklich und wir brauchen ja wir
brauchen eine starke
innerhalb der Ampel wir haben wir haben
ja wir haben ja tatsächlich also wir
haben ja wir haben ja tatsächlich der
Bundestag unter demokratie braucht eine
starke Opposition stellt keine zumindest
in der FDP nicht in Frage und dann muss
auch viel kommen aber jetzt einfach zu
sagen wir digitalisieren jetzt die
gaspreisbremse obwohl unser Land 0,0
digital ist wir haben die größte größte
wohngeldreform seit dem Krieg auf dem
Weg gebracht die Kommunen sagen uns wir
kriegen die nicht gewuppt weil wir zu
viel mit der Bürokratie zu tun haben so
und jetzt zu sagen die Lösung ist Mensch
digitalisiert das doch noch schnell dann
geht's alles das ist nicht realistisch
vorgeschlagen hat was mich auch brennend
interessiert und ich hoffe sie alle am
Tisch auch ich fand die Frage gerade
ganz spannend diese gestellt haben warum
muss jemand der 30.000 Euro
Jahreseinkommen hat das auch noch
versteuern warum lässt man den Bürgern
nicht mehr Geld das ist eigentlich eine
Frage die sehr sehr spannend ist aber
nicht die Steuern sondern die
Sozialabgaben die ihr bezahlt das ist
nämlich viel viel mehr Geld als die
Steuerzahler man könnte mit den Steuern
anfangen ich wäre auch sofort dafür
dafür gibt es keine Mehrheit im
Deutschen Bundestag und gab es schon
vorher nicht weil wir ja mit der
spd-kolliert haben deswegen ging es auch
vorher nicht aber das eigentliche
Problem ist natürlich die Sozialabgaben
sie haben völlig mit Recht die Rente
angesprochen die natürlich teurer wird
das ist gar keine Frage weil einfach
mehr Leute alt werden und wenn dann mein
Jahrgang der stärkste je war irgendwann
den Personen geht dann jedes Jahr schon
mehr als 100 Milliarden rein die die der
der eigentlich die eigentliche Frage
sind die Sozialabgaben und ähm der
Sozialstaat wird in einem Maße teuer das
irgendwann die Leute sehr sehr viel Geld
von ihrem verdienten Geld abgeben müssen
und die FDP hat
ist jetzt gerade dabei sich für einen
Bürgergeld einzusetzen dass wir im
Bundesrat erstmal gestoppt haben bei der
man wie bitte das ist Wahnsinn der
absolute Wahnsinn so und wir sind weil
sie das eben gesagt haben wir sind dazu
da die Regierung zu kritisieren
unser Job und wir können momentan nicht
selber abgewählt worden sind wir
hinnehmen also sind wir diejenigen
beurteilen zusammenfassen da gibt es
wenn es da eine eine also wenn ich jetzt
einmal zusammenfassen darf die
Steuerentlastung oder auch die Abgaben
gibt es nicht wegen der SPD die ja
eigentlich dafür da ist dem kleinen Mann
zu helfen das Wort ist übrigens ihr blöd
vom Politikern gewählt aber so ist es
macht ja wenigsten SPD hat sehr sehr
viel blockiert was wir gerne gemacht
hätten das ist so Ausrede sagen und
dasselbe Problem ist die FDP deswegen
darf ich sie nicht vor
das ist nun mal so die mehr Verhältnisse
sind so wie sie sind das haben die
Bilder so entschieden deswegen gibt es
eine zu hohe Staatsquote in Deutschland
und im übrigen natürlich auch irgendwann
werden Schulden gehen nie weg Schulden
werden bleiben und das ist noch viel
größere Problem als der Sachsen
Schuldenproblem
wenn ich jetzt einmal das Wort noch habe
in einem Punkt bin ich nicht ihrer
Meinung der Klimawandel wenn wir den
nicht aufhalten das wird die teuerste
Veranstaltung die wir uns überhaupt je
vorgestellt haben weil das wahnsinnig
viele Konflikte darstellt der
amerikanische Begriff ist frisch
escalator also das heißt der Fahrstuhl
mit den Problemen mit drei Milliarden
Leute Welt nicht da bleiben können wo
sie heute leben weil es klimatisch nicht
mehr geht sie kommen ja auch direkt von
der Klimakonferenz
das Thema
schlechthin
aber wenn wir wenn wir wenn wir den
klima
wandel stoppen wollen dann müssen wir
auf Innovation setzen wir auch Wachstum
setzen ich würde sogar weitergehen auf
verzichten und wir brauchen ein
marktwirtschaftliches System dass diesen
Wachstum das Wachstum belohnt im Bereich
der Klimatechnik und die Innovation
befeuert aber ich habe jetzt einen
dringendes Bedürfnis noch mal drauf zu
reagieren auf die Rente ja unsere
Sozialsystem steht vor dem Kollaps es
ist jetzt ein Einstieg gelungen zwar nur
drei Milliarden aber es sind immerhin 10
Milliarden immerhin gedecktes System ein
bisschen weniger aber es ist uns
bewusstiger Natur ist aufgegangen wir
müssen unsere Sozialsysteme tatsächlich
umbauen da gibt es die eine Seite die
sagt naja dann sollen die Leute immer
mehr zahlen das ist nicht unsere
Positionierung müssen verzichten anders
wäre es gar nicht zu schaffen deswegen
gibt es ja auch eine gewisse
Rentenformel aber wichtig ist dass wir
Sozialsysteme umbauen und noch mal beim
Punkt der Entlastung
1 Komma beim 1,3fachen des
durchschnittlichen Lohns ist mir schon
eine Spitzensteuersatz
sehen ja genau aber man kann doch den
Leuten mehr Geld natürlich sind die
sozial mehr bei ich habe das sogar vor
wenigen Tagen nachgeschaut extra da ist
dann der Unterschied zwischen 1700 nett
und nur steuern und 2000 das sind dann
schon die Steuern das ist jetzt nicht
die Welt aber das ist vielleicht genau
das ja genau also gerade wenn man so
wenig verdient dann ist es vielleicht
auch Geld dass man den Menschen mehr
lassen
wir jetzt ist es jetzt machen es wird
glaube ich dieses Jahr noch fertig oder
Anfang nächstes Jahr wir werden
zumindestens das Bausparen neu Anreizen